هربا من ازمات وحروب في بلدانهم الاصليه
يتجمع على طرفي سكه القطار المهجوره هذه
شماليه فرنسا مهاجرون من جنسيات افغانيه
وسودانيه وحتى سوريه املا بتحقيق حلم
العبور من فرنسا الى بريطانيا لكن عبر
قوارب متهالكه في البحر هنا اقام
المهاجرون في غابات مدينه كالي عالم
موازيا ينغلق على نفسه وينقسم الى مجموعات
السوداني مع السوداني والافغاني مع
الافغاني اما لحظه التقاء الجميع فهي فقط
حين تاتي المساعدات وسائل الاعلام غير
المرحبا بها هنا لان قنوات فرنسيه دابت
على شيطنت هؤلاء والتحريض عليهم فسرعان ما
تعاله الاصوات معترضه على وجودنا
طب اتفضل
الجمعيات ان الشرطه الفرنسيه مسؤوله عن
هذا الوضع فقبل يوم من وصولنا جرفت مركبات
الشرطه خياما وطعاما واغطيه ثم غادر
التريكه مئات المهاجرين في برد قارس لقتل
حلمهم في العبور الى بريطانيا
بارد
جدا
الشرطه صادرت حتى المساعدات التي احضرناها
وضعوا حواجز لكي يمنع المنظمات من المرور
وتقديم المساعده للمهاجرين
لان طلب لجوءه رفض في فرنسا وبعض اخر يسعى
للمشمل مع عائله له هناك لهنجاوه مهاجر
كردي ايراني قابل بالتحدث الينا بعد رفض
عشرات من زملائه فقدنا بعيدا عن تجمعات
المهاجرين والمهربين الذين يندسون بينهم
منتحلين صفه مهاجر حتى لا نثيره غضبهم
بريطانيا
لهذا السبب الكل يريد الذهاب الى بريطانيا
الوضع هنا سيء جدا الطقس بارد والشرطه
عدوانيه انها تاتي باستمرار لتصادر خيامنا
واكياس النوم نحن لسنا بخير هنا قبل عام
تماما غرق قارب يقول له 27 مهاجرا ابحر من
شواطئ كاليه بعض المهاجرين هنا اسمعوا
بالقصه لان الغابه هي محطه عبور لا اكثر
تتجدد فيها الوجوه لكن الحلم واحد بالنسبه
للجميع وهو الوصول الى شواطئ بريطانيا
التي يمكن رؤيتها بالعين المجرده فادده
العربيه كاليه